hello I'm allegedly andrew heaton and
this is mostly weekly Thursday the FCC
voted to begin the process of peeling
back Obama era internet regulations in
other words the Internet is free ballin
again
so what is net neutrality it sounds like
a volleyball competition in Switzerland
but actually it's a thing that regulates
the internet the place where I do most
of my shopping Jeeves
asking and you're facing your face is my
startup where you post pictures of
things and then people rate how much
they look like your face net neutrality
forbids internet providers from charging
different rates we're providing
different speeds for different data it
does so by defining the internet as a
public utility through a law literally
designed for 19th century railroads
which reminds me of my app strangers on
a train you know when you need to murder
someone well this allows you to swap
murders with someone on the train
hashtag murder here before this FCC vote
the government could micromanage the
internet and in case you've forgotten
this is the government the FCC is the
governmental body regulating the
internet the self-same agency tasked
with regulating Janet Jackson's nipple
slips and Steve Colbert's use of the
phrase [ __ ] holster dammit the Internet
is nipple slips and [ __ ] holsters the
alternative policy is not fiddling with
it which is exactly how the internet
operated until February of 2015 despite
what you're reading on Twitter
corporations did not just take over the
Internet these net neutrality rules have
only been around two years before that
for the last 30 years the internet
doesn't have those rules and I think it
worked out pretty well with the
exception of 4chan salon.com and popup
ads once net neutrality is repealed
companies are free to charge premium
rates and speeds which is completely
normal in other industries even the post
office has Priority Mail standard first
class and lost to make an analogy there
are these things called highways and net
neutrality effectively mandates that the
passing lane goes the same speed as the
right lane with that stupid old person
from Florida won't turn off our goddamn
blinker and look I get why people hate
cable providers they're terrible but
Facebook Google Twitter and Amazon are
also big scary corporations and they
support net neutrality which seems
ominous almost as if large corporations
like regulatory birds that mostly if
that small Starbucks
please I can subscribe net neutrality is
supposed to stop cable companies from
slowing down websites they don't like
that refused to pay them the only
problem is this has never actually
happened the closest thing occurred in
2010 when metro pcs offered a budget
data plan that had unlimited YouTube
streaming but not unlimited Netflix and
Hulu because it was harder to compress
them so net neutrality is a solution in
search of a problem and here's a list of
other things with sound like problems
but on the other big dark hypothetical
is that cable companies will block or
since your websites they don't like
which has happened exactly 0 times we
don't know how the Internet's going to
evolve or what kind of interesting
holographic pornography we'll be into 10
years from now it could be that we'll
need super ultra fast service to watch
that hollow point but we can use older
slower service to say mean things about
me on YouTube we don't know how the
Internet's going to evolve and neither
does the FCC John Oliver made net
neutrality a cause de jour but one of
the problems those of us who disagree
have is we don't even have a slogan we
can fit on a bumper sticker so how about
organic internet quit fiddling with it
he also started a website called Go FCC
or self.com for fans to register their
support of net neutrality well if you
support an organic internet you can go
to our website that we started FCC yeah
you know me calm I am told that's a wrap
thing you can go there and play
minesweeper because the internet works
best doing its own thing good day
[Music]